from what little remains of the ruined
Bridge Narendra Modi could see across
the Machu River and how far the victims
fell more than a hundred people died on
Sunday when a century and a half old
suspension bridge collapsed into the
river
India's prime minister visited morby
Gujarat to see for himself
below Rescuers and inflatable dinghies
were still looking for bodies a job made
more difficult by dense vegetation
growing on the river surface
after visiting the site of the disaster
Modi traveled to the hospital he spoke
with some of the hundreds of people
who'd been on the bridge when the cables
gave way and thanked the doctors and
nurses looking after them
there's anger among survivors they say
negligence was partly to blame
the company managing the bridge is
responsible for this mishap the public
is also responsible as they were
deliberately swinging the bridge so many
together shouldn't have been allowed
there were 500 to 600 people on the
bridge
on the bridge we were three friends the
bridge collapsed for us one of our
friends died because of this incident
in the capital New Delhi protesters
demanded increased compensation for all
victims injured and families of those
killed several people were detained
footage shows a crowded Bridge just
before it collapsed the bridge only
reopened last week after months of
renovation nine people including
ticketing clocks and contractors were
arrested on Monday
Gujarat is Narendra modi's home state
and it's announced a day of mourning for
Wednesday Rory challenge Al Jazeera